auch die kinderrechte springst du ich
wollte damals nur so mit dem geld neue
spitze da diese ja okay das ist jetzt
wirklich schmerzhaft herzlich kommen zu
diesem video das hier ist der zweite
teil meiner reaktion auf die legendäre
mädchengang von hilft mir falls ihr den
ersten teil noch nicht gesehen habt
check-in zuerst mal ab bis der erste
link in der beschreibung für die camper
mit die ganze erste folge zu schauen und
die noch nicht gesehen hat gibt's jetzt
hier eine kurze zusammenfassung von dem
was in der erste bürger passiert ist
also ja eben schon gesehen stellt euch
auf mensch nicht abstoßend dass des
absturz abstoßend das verhalten ein die
hochgefährliche hochentzündliche girl
gegen ist gerade dabei eine handtasche
zu klauen und ja wir erinnern uns alle
noch also die mädchen-gang das sind
diese drei auf der rechten seite und
diese einfach angezogen wirklich also es
ist unter aller sau also ich habe keine
ahnung von outfits für mädels wirklich
null und selbst ich kann sagen das
kannst du nicht trocken es geht nicht
klar was los war mein persönliches
highlight ist wirklich immer noch wenn
dieser bliebe der rechts einmal die
golde bauchtasche und dann das t shirt
auf dem steht go [ __ ] ihrer hashtags 11
damit ist eigentlich alles über diese
menschen gesagt aber schauen wir mal was
jetzt machen
ich wollte doch nur eine handtasche
klauen
ich weiß der schubst mich wächst ein
laster meiner tasche klar was soll der
scheiß sagt auch noch irgendjemanden was
dank hatte ich richtig ja leute also es
geht unter aller sau weiter ab die die
gefürchtete mädchen gegen die nicht
meinen namen hat deswegen heißt mädchen
gegen terrorisiert weiter die straße von
berlin jetzt hier mit dem absoluten
gangster move irgendeiner streberin aus
ihrer schule ist es glaube ich die
handtasche zu ziehen damit für die man
sich natürlich an spectors den straßen
das ist mal ganz klar wirklich gut
gemacht naja ganz ehrlich leute für alle
ich ja soll ich gecheckt
[Gelächter]
was eigentlich wirklich komplett wird
also ihr seht ihr diese komischen dollar
ketten die die umhänge haben ja das ist
das geschenk sein von denen also das ist
der in gang
erkennungszeichen also sie sind wirklich
in so einer ein euro shop angegangen
haben sich drei von den dingen geholt
und das ist jetzt der entgelt zeichnen
also die sind schon ziemlich am anfang
und mit den 20 euro ich warte kraft ja
viel spaß damit
mit 20 euro wird party gemacht okay also
ich verstehe sie als schüler ist es
vielleicht ein bisschen was anderes
davon geht er aber so 20 euro wollt ihr
party machen
im club die gehe jetzt in seinem club
rhein ok also machen sie richtig party
da holen sie sich ein preisgeld zwei
wodka energy und reißende land komplett
ab
pro rolle ob du das gehört sich lassen
lassen
warten krach kein zweifel leute so redet
man auf den straßen von berlin die
schwarte krachen lassen
das trikot
[Musik]
ok also scheinbar in ihrer schule
das geschulte auge erkennt sie haben
alle ihr outfit einmal gewechselt das
geschulte auge erkennt auch das ist
wirklich kein bisschen besser geworden
ist
so ganz recht so und niemals abhängig
gemacht dass die logi an der stelle
verstehe ich auch nicht so ganz also die
jungs sind ja in dem raum und zocken
tischkicker und die mädels kommen dann
rein setzten sich auf den tisch in
diesem raum wo die jungs tischkicker
spielen so wie hättet überall sonst in
der schule sein können so aber ihr setzt
euch auf den tisch und wird im
oberkörper geöffnet zu den jungs richtig
gespielt
allerdings schaut rüber was guckst du so
das ist nun mal einer erklären du
brauchst einen richtigen kleinen nicht
so ein mensch kiwi der last der angst
richtig froh oder es also ich würde also
ich hab es auch im ersten teil von
dieser zweiteiligen serie schon gesagt
ihr seid eigentlich nicht in der
position andere leute dafür zu
kritisieren was sie anhaben okay was
trägt er hier so kann man brille jeans
normales t shirt okay seit 2002 von
porsche drauf steht so ein kind sechs
server was auch immer das bedeutet okay
aber sie dagegen sieht einfach aus wie
ein verkehrsunfall muss man so sagen
aber ich hab' ich letztens doch noch die
ganze zeit miteinander
hängen sehen ja die hat mich nicht in
ruhe gelassen wahrscheinlich geht ja auf
mich aber was der anhört sagt sie werden
die kommen wirklich sich darüber hinweg
die ein euro shop dollar zeichenkette
klimpert naja also wenn du nicht auf ihn
stets dann stürzte das sicher nicht mein
lebenssinn kohle ab und oder gehabt doch
keine cola mit dem es doch nichts zu
holen
okay okay okay als ob das jetzt so weit
geht der ja also sie hier links mit
ihrem bezaubernden laut wird ist wie
seine position sich über andere lustig
zu machen ist ja klar dann aber sie hier
links hat man kann ebenso an ihren
blicken gesehen ist wahrscheinlich voll
verknallt in diesem typ mit dem weißen
t-shirt jetzt von den anderen gamern den
auftrag einfach mal diesen jungen aus
zunehmend menschen ziemlich abstoßend
ich erkenne nur wie macht zu holen sind
wir nicht aber eigentlich finde ich die
idee gar nicht mal so schlecht stellte
ich doch nicht so an das spiel bestimmt
noch ein paar euros von seiner mama
haben ja das ganze hier also diese
dieses schmieden von plänen darüber
welcher spiesser jetzt abgezogen wird
und auch ein cash hat oder nicht und ob
man ihn verliebt oder nicht auf voller
lautstärke passiert wir dürfen sie
vergessen leute einfach so dass zwei
meter zwei meter entfernt von den jungs
alles klappt
[Musik]
ich gehe ja schon die zwei meter drüber
zu diesem typen der safe nichts davon
gehört auch dass wir gerade besprochen
haben also pro also entweder du bist
wirklich kauft so du hast einfach als
mensch aber das kann keine höhere organ
okay du hast keine ohren und hast es
deswegen nicht gehört dass menschen die
anderthalb meter von ihr entfernt waren
gerade was platten dein kumpel
abzuziehen oder aber es weiß lass ich
mal diese mädels im glitzerkleid mein
kumpel mal aus dem perfekten überhaupt
nicht das ist jetzt wirklich schmerzhaft
er reist wirklich aus der haut richtig
weihnachten aber leute brenzlige
situation möglicherweise ist er der
erste in dieser unterdrückten statt der
der mädchengang paroli bietet ich bin
jetzt kein experte in solchen sachen
aber funktioniert so ausrauben dass man
hingeht und sagt bitte
jetzt kommt die weiter zeigt sich leute
den ganzen verbrecher weltweit in den
letzten jahrzehnten jahrhunderten haben
es immer falsch gemacht und dieser ganze
scheiß mit vorgehaltener waffe und so
leute aus haben ist okay hier wird euch
gezeigt wie man es richtig macht auf der
straße nicht gegängelt gehen hin zu
ihren aufwand und sagen bitte bitte
bitte dein geld geben muss man kindern
[Musik]
zurück oder
warum ist es immer so bei hilf mir es
macht überhaupt keinen sinn man tiefen
und erhaltung auf zimmerlautstärke was
ich zum check das ist laut und dann
dreht sie sich um geht zu 50 zentimeter
weiter und ihre freundin nichts von der
unterhaltung hört wie funktioniert so
die die ausbreitung von schalen et 2 ich
glaube ich mensch mila hast du voll gut
gemacht den typen da gerade abzuziehen
über was habt ihr eigentlich gerade
gerät wir haben überhaupt nichts gehört
weiß ja wie das ist wenn man 75
zentimeter voneinander entfernt sitzt
dann hört man einfach gar nichts mehr
erst recht nicht in geschlossenen räumen
wo auch kein störgeräusch von außen
reinkommt hast du denn da eigentlich mit
dem mode
ich habe den keiner gesagt und das macht
was ich fange ich war lange aber ein
milan 1 klaus geld musst du echt noch
arbeiten
ja du du lädst einfach eigentlich muss
nicht an einen klaus kills arbeiten du
kannst einfach so einfach aufhören mit
leuten zu tun die plastik dollarzeichen
um den hals tragen
schritt nummer eins schritt nummer zwei
einfach normaler mensch sein
also leute das hört auch wirklich nicht
auf die körperverletzung durch grausame
outfits geht weiter wir sind jetzt hier
bloß leopardenmuster mit pinken top
darunter natürlich der goldkette mit
mein leben ja auf jeden fall das mit
doch gleich nach dass auf jeden fall
haben jetzt heute sehen wir hier die
mädchen gang bei ihrem eigentlichen
haupt geschäftsmodell das ist auch die
art und weise wie sie ihren ganzen
lifestyles finanzieren
gangster leben auf großem fuß nistler
[Musik]
ihr wisst ihr was leute an der stelle an
der stelle muss ich wirklich sagen wo
also das ist jetzt wirklich das zu viel
auf einmal okay ich glaube an der
schotte ist der punkt für mich gekommen
wir sehen hier noch mal die georgier
aufkreuzen wieder in aber sowas von
aggressiv sich beißenden farben die
komplette gang trick pink und türkis
kombiniert mit den maximalen augenkrebs
ich dafür muss man zudem nicht sagen
oder schreibt ihr unten in die
kommentare wie viel respekt ihr
persönlich vor der mädchengang haben
würdet ihr euch vorgestellt das video ab
hier könne man kann aber den video
gefallen hat das war es was mir heute
große raum macht's gut